stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir en soit merci d'être avec
nous cette année a été celle de votre
envol selon le maine libre vous êtes
passé de l'anonymat ou presque au statut
de ministre donc responsabilité
d'ailleurs que vous vous y étiez préparé
à ne pas obtenir mais ce n'est pas à
votre dépens que françois hollande que
vous accompagner au plus près depuis dix
ans a choisi de manifester son
ingratitude qu'il revendique d'ailleurs
désormais comme chef de l'état on
parlera de la présidence hollande et de
vous avec perrine tarneaud tout à
l'heure perrine tarneaud de public sénat
et avec samir tounsi de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire des
premières décisions prises ou attendu de
la place et de l'avenir du parti
socialiste vous voulez un ps rangés
derrière les couleurs du hollandisme
pour rester au pouvoir dix ans ainsi que
vous l'écrivez dans une tribune publiée
par le monde noter que les
téléspectateurs interviennent au cours
de cette émission par le biais de
l'application tilly tchèque de notre
partenaire orange d'abord au risque de
vous choquer en plein drame social
est ce que le volailler doux mérite
d'être sauvé vous défendez un élevage de
qualité d'où ne fait cuisiner des
poulets 2 me selon le critique
gastronomique du monde 2 qui pose cette
question sacrilège
il pose cette question il oublie une
chose c'est que derrière l'entreprise
d'où le nom il ya 4000 salariés 800 à
900 éleveurs et c'est ça qui m'importe
et qui importe aussi arnaud montebourg
et guillaume garot qui travaillent avec
moi maintenant c'est de cela dont il
s'agit et en même temps il s'agit d'une
production de poulets de bas de gamme
certes mais qui aujourd'hui en france
voient 40 % de notre consommation être
importés donc les deux réunis mérite que
l'état dans la mesure de ce qu'il peut
faire soit à l'écouté et surtout cherche
à trouver une solution pour nous at il
déposé ces éleveurs ils sont 800
bien sûr on pense à eux ils sont
entraînés dans une course folle depuis
des années par d'où on le sait ils
produisent au bout de cinquante jours
des poulets qui n'ont pas de goût qui
n'ont pas d'eau qui n'ont pas de locaux
qui n'ont pas d'eau qui des poulets qui
avaient des débouchés à l'exportation
jusqu'à six qui ont bien sûr sûrement il
y aura à réfléchir sur l'évolution de
cette filière oui peut pas dire que ça
se présentait aussi par les poulets de
bresse
mais pour les volets mais là c'est de
louer un autre il faut que vous sachiez
quand même les plaies de bresse où il
peut y louer c'est un poulet qui coûte
plus cher que tout le monde et ça je
vais le dire ce soir de manière très
claire aujourd'hui il y a de plus en
plus de français qui n'ont pas accès
quotidiennement à la nourriture
pas parce qu'ils ne veulent pas parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas c'est comme la
question de la santé et donc on a un
problème dans une crise comme montre
avec que nous traversons avec le chômage
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui on
apprenne d'accès la nourriture donc on
ne peut pas considérer tournoi manger du
poulet de bresse malheureusement
malheureusement et il y a en france en
plus des gens qui consomment du poulet
mais partie pas complet ça reste
d'ailleurs une spécificité française qui
est lié au modèle du repas français
mais au-delà de ça il ya aussi des gens
qui consomment du poulet autrement des
cuisses des ailes ou qui consomment du
poulet dans différents produits
donc on est bien obligé de répondre à
cette demande dans aujourd'hui les
syndicats du volailler doux craignent la
casse sociale et le dépeçage de
l'entreprise ce ils auront les deux noms
je pense qu'aujourd'hui malgré le fait
que l'offre qui a été fait aujourd'hui
il y en aura peut-être d'autres puisque
le tribunal n'a pas encore décidé il ya
des reprises qui sont proposées elles ne
sont pas suffisantes
on doit travailler pour améliorer en
particulier au niveau social ce qui est
proposé aujourd'hui c'est tout le débat
que nous pouvons avoir
et c'est le débat que nous aurons dans
les semaines dans les jours qui viennent
mais on peut pas dire qu'il y ait aucune
possibilité de pérenniser une grande
partie de l'activité grâce à ça c'est
déjà acté maintenant il faut qu'on
progresse accord est ce que le
patriarche charles doux qu'à 75 ans
devra rendre des comptes
écoutez le patriarche a été celui qui a
piloté et diriger
l'entreprise pendant des années il ya eu
la phase d'expansion et puis il ya eu
après des phases catastrophique de choix
stratégiques qui remettent en cause
aujourd'hui la viabilité et la pérennité
de lançon de l'outil il a fait des
investissements au brésil
inconsidérés et aujourd'hui il ya une
dette de plus de 300 millions d'euros
qui pèsent sur ces entreprises et qui
pèsent sur lui et quand il les rend déjà
déballé compte c'est vrai trop les
renversements ils voient qu'ils rendent
des comptes il y aura des comptes à
rendre quelle forme bah écoutez par le
fait qu' aujourd'hui dans la situation
dans laquelle se trouve la diffi la
proposition qui est faite c'est une
reprise mais pas avec charles doux temps
lui bah écoutez et là tout faire pour
s'accrocher il s'accroche s'allongera
sur nous mais c'est fini moi je pense
que pour relancer cette activité il y
aura une difficulté à ce que l'on reste
dans un périmètre qui soit décidée par
charles doux donc l'avenir du volailler
doux se fera sans charles doux voilà ce
que je fais avec l'objectif de
pérenniser l'activité les salariés et
surtout venez au producteur de volaille
alors vous connaissez bien votre secteur
ministériel stéphane le foll vous l'avez
suivi comme député européen
est ce que vous le voyez comme un
secteur industriel il ya les deux c'est
un secteur qui comporte une diversité
très grande à la fois des circuits
courts la production agricole d'abord
donc l'agriculture secteur primaire on a
oublié sa vocabulaire et ça existe et
c'est important
et j'entends bien défendre ce secteur
primaire et puis ce secteur primaire il
a aussi un secteur secondaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'industrie
agroalimentaire et qui à diverses formes
il ya des petits de transformation jadis
circuits courts il ya des circuits
moyens et puis il ya de la grande
industrie dont côté en l'état à la fois
l'aide du primaire l'économie et le
secteur primaire est aussi dans le
domaine du secteur secondaire
vous êtes confrontés à différents
segments du marché j'ai envie de dire ce
que vous êtes confrontés à des lobbys
dans votre activité professionnelle
ministériel en fruits dire plus tôt je
vais vous alliez reçu des cadeaux des
votre nomination nous et que j'ai
renvoyé au domaine donc et foulards de
markit
vous c'est qu'ils tentaient de vous
séduire c'est parce que je m'en suis pas
préoccupé
j'ai renvoyé tout ça au domaine a donc
ceux qui veulent me séduire il fait
l'objet des propositions et ses
propositions elle porte sur des grands
sujets l'avenir de l'agriculture
française la prise en compte de
l'environnement l'avenir de l'industrie
agroalimentaire et de la transformation
de l'ensemble des produits
et puis la pérennité de l'agriculture et
des agriculteurs sur montceau la
victoire ceux là sont reçus et les
discussions sont faites
après il ya des gens qui défendent des
intérêts vous pensez bien que dans tous
les domaines des gens défendent des
intérêts la question du cruiser osr
décisions prises
eh bien vous avez vu que l'entreprise
qui commercialise ce produit mais décide
tueur d'abeilles
vous l'avez regardé tout de suite voilà
n'est pas content tu ne fais savoir que
ces arrêts malgré ses réticences et
résistances de certains lobbys
industriels en effet la preuve
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à les grands
joint même que par exemple le cruiser
vous l'avez maintenu par exemple pour le
maïs et quand je juge puisque je juge
sur des faits scientifiques
j'avais eu à la fois ce qui avait été
produit par la revue science et ensuite
la vie qui avait été donné par lens est
sur cette base là je n'ai pas hésité
les autorités à autoriser les avis
divergent sauf que là elle a validé
l'étude qui avait prouvé que c'est
famille de molécules en particulier pour
le colza avait des conséquences très
importantes et très négatif sur et la
capacité des abeilles à retourner à la
forme est là on est là on prend une
décision vous prenez une décision et y
en aura d'autres par exemple au sénat
fait voyager un peu partout en france
une mission d'information sur les
pesticides qui donc multiplié visites
sur les terrains est-ce que vous allez
éventuellement interdit d'autres
pesticides demain mais ça va dépendre de
l'évaluation et la nocivité de ces
pesticides mois le principe plutôt large
qui va être équivalent guider c'est
comment je fais pour changer les modèles
de production et limiter le recours aux
pesticides de la même manière qu aux
herbicides
c'est un enjeu non pas simplement à
l'enjeu environnemental
bien sûr et c'est en même temps un enjeu
économique une question c'est ça le
débat sur sa jument d'interdire aux
questions très simples votre
prédécesseur
l'agriculture avait autorisé le retour
des épandages par avion ça n'était pas
autorisée dans le grenelle de
l'environnement est ce que là vous allez
vivre dans votre dans ce groupe à y
allons connaître l'âge et la baule et
bien sûr des dangers il ya des problèmes
aussi qui sont liées spécifiquement ça
ne peut être que par dérogation sur un
problème ponctuel est monté de la mairie
à une maladie qui se développe
rapidement et sur lequel il faut qu' une
décision qui soit prise ça ne peut être
que dans ce cas là on doit sortir de
cette logique
comment dirais-je qui a consisté à
utiliser les produits chimiques avec une
masse et la continuité donc il y aura
jésus en location et oui quand il ya des
problèmes
et quand je n'ai pas l'alternative c'est
difficile de faire autrement d'accord
d'accord donc fait un recul par rapport
au grenelle de l'environnement pas un
recul par rapport aux vrais de
l'environnement puisque vous savez très
bien que dans ce chrono avait été prévu
la règle elle ne souffre que de
dérogation dans les cas ultime
donc je reste sur cette logique là est
toute la question qui est posée c'est
pas simplement dire je vais interdire
les épandages quand il ya un gros
problème c'est de joules répète changer
les modèles de production pour éviter le
moins possible d'avoir recours à la
chimie est le plus beau lagon
alors voilà la nature est est ce que les
ogm peuvent être une alternative aux
pesticides aux produits phytosanitaires
l'accusation nous allons vous trop
peureux
face à ces organismes génétiquement vous
sachiez qu'il ya deux types de gm
aujourd'hui sur le marché des ogm qui
résistent des herbicides 1-1 ogm une
plante un maïs en l'occurrence il
résiste à un herbicide spécifique vous
suspectez l'herbicide il reste rien que
la plante qui résistent premier ogm
deuxième aux gestes ces ogm qui
produisent eux mêmes des pesticides et
ça ça me convient pas du tout à d'accord
ça ne me convient pas du tout et qu'on
vienne pas me raconter qu'avec ce genre
d'évolution
on va changer et faire évoluer les
choses non il ya bien d'autres
techniques
d'autres modèles de production qui
permettent de faire beaucoup mieux sans
avoir recours à ce type de gm s'est pas
pour autant d'ailleurs quand suite sur
les cautions d'évolution génétique pour
que les plans d'amélioration culié un
certain nombre de qualités qui peuvent
être recherchées résistance au stress
idée que je prenais pas de la betterave
sur un peu plus de sucre dans la
betterave ça c'est des évolutions qui
peuvent être intéressantes et qui dans
le cadre d'un développement dans la
nature ne pose pas de problème
là on a quand même des ogm
qui sont résistants à certains
herbicides on a aujourd'hui aux états
unis des plantes qui deviennent
résistantes elles mêmes à ses services
il est donc un problème
ensuite pour la nature de manière
surtout pour les productions à l'école
tu à propos de la nature est ce que vous
êtes derrière les éleveurs de haute
savoie où des vosges eux qui perdent de
leur troupeau en ce moment en raison de
la présence de loups on parle même de
meute dans les vosges aujourd'hui il ya
un problème de cohabitation sérieux
qu'il faudra qu'il avait un traité une
espèce de mon avis que ministre il ya
des prédateurs qui sont arrivés il ya
deux solutions on éradique tout mais je
réponds à la question est ce que c'est
ça la solution
non je pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve des
voies et des moyens mais je comprends
aussi en même temps que des éleveurs
aujourd'hui trouve que dans les
conditions actuelles
et bien c'est payé cher la présence de
prédateurs donc il faut qu'on trouve des
voies et des moyens pour faire évoluer
les choses et aujourd'hui on en est pas
encore là
malheureusement d'accord on a parlé des
lobbys est ce que pour vous la puissante
fnsea est un lobby
non c'est un grand syndicat qui défend
les intérêts de son syndicat
je veux pas trahir la quoi que ce soit
de la même manière que la confédération
paysanne défend un certain type
d'agriculture et un certain nombre
d'alliances vrai pour une plus grande
diversité fait des résolutions agricole
j'ai fait déjà des propositions de
réformes dans le cadre des élections
professionnelles et des chambres
d'agriculture pour en particulier
favorisé la représentativité au niveau
régional assuré aussi une majorité pour
pouvoir gouverner les chambres
d'agriculture mais on avance et je
continuerai faire l'opposition dans ce
domaine alors je note que dans la
situation économique si difficile que
nous traversons les agriculteurs voient
leurs revenus augmenter
vous avez vous même devoir accompagner
la réforme de la politique agricole
commune vous avez annoncé également une
loi cadre de l'agriculture sur
l'agriculture sont pour l'an prochain
on n'a pas compris à quoi servait auprès
de vous guillaume garot donc comme
ministre délégué à l'agroalimentaire oui
vous l'avez site il y a un instinct mais
on s'est dit il est là uniquement pour
apaiser la colère de ségolène royal il
ya d'abord ce cas là me guillaume garot
maire de laval députés et qui
aujourd'hui et demain va suivre toute la
question posée par le groupe
particulier qui va mener aussi ce qu'on
avait anticipé et prévu et c'est lui qui
en aura toute la charge des grandes
tables rondes sur l'avenir de
l'industrie et bien sûr domaine là y'a
un rôle et ça me permettra moi de me
concentrer sur une grande question qui
la réforme de la politique agricole
commune très bien aller le gouvernement
est à l'oeuvre dans un contexte
budgétaire difficile vous avez reçu
votre lettre de cadrage comme l'on dit
alors quel est le montant des économies
à réaliser pour vous quelles sont
conséquents les conséquences dans la
gestion du ministère de l'agriculture
vous allez pouvoir nous le dira mais
d'abord avant d'accueillir samedi à
thoune c'est de l' agence france presse
qui nous attend l'enquète de marib remo
le ministère de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt n'est
pas épargné par la cure d'austérité
générale bien au contraire il se murmure
même que le portefeuille de
l'agriculture serait des plus exposés
mais pour les syndicats l'heure de la
rigueur a sonné depuis bien longtemps
en dix ans le ministère a perdu huit
mille agents
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que 36
milles je me demande où on va trouver
des économies au niveau du ministère de
l'agriculture soit deux choses on les
prend sur les effectifs et je voudrais
rappeler que en matière d'effectifs le
ministre d'agriculture a déjà plus de
1000 départs en retraite
tous les ans depuis 2002 diminuent
comment dix mille agents sont partis
remplacés
trois départs par un une embauche les
enseignants agricoles représentent la
majeure partie des effectifs du
ministère de l'agriculture
il ne dépend donc pas du ministère dit
prioritaire de l'éducation nationale
alors même si au cabinet de stéphane le
foll on promet l'ouverture de postes
dans l'enseignement agricole
les craintes persistent au vu d'une
réalité dégradé on assiste à des
fermetures de classes à des fermetures
il complète des fois où à des
regroupements de d'établissement ou
alors on pousse effectivement les jeunes
soient allés vers l'ancien banquier vous
faire l'apprentissage au delà des
effectifs il faudra au ministre a
arbitré les dépenses d'intervention ce
qui signifie externalisée privatiser
certaines missions dans le viseur du
ministère le contrôle sanitaire des
abattoirs on envisager plus comprendre
de supprimer ces contrôleurs pour y
mettre des salariés des abattoirs par
exemple bien entendu il est des risques
alimentaires derrière ces gens là sont
formés ils sont assermentés et on mettre
un salarié qu'un pouvoir hiérarchique au
dessus de lui bien entendu c'est pas la
même chose
de nombreuses pistes d'économies peuvent
être envisagées suppression de certains
opérateurs ces établissements publics
qui dépendent du ministère transfert des
compétences aux collectivités locales
les syndicats honteux de nombreuses
doléances à exposer aux ministres lors
des négociations en interne qui ont lieu
tout au long du mois de juillet voilà
samir conseiller de l'agencé france
presse et avec nos penseurs samir vos
questions au ministre de l'agriculture
bonsoir c'est fernand pon la rigueur un
mot tabou pour un gouvernement de gauche
non mais personne n'a caché pendant
cette campagne présidentielle qu'il
allait il allait être nécessaire d'avoir
de faire des efforts compte tenu de la
situation économique ou connaissez et
compte tenu de ce que n'a pu mesurer et
trouvé en arrivant
personne n'a dit autre chose donc il
s'agit d'être conformes au budget aux
objectifs qu'on s'est fixés à la fois de
réduction des déficits budgétaires
quatre et demi cette année 3 l'année
prochaine pour un objectif de 0 en 2017
c'est ça qui reste la ligne
donc on a besoin de rester conforme aux
engagements qui ont été pris par le
président de la république
alors on appelle ça de la rigueur mais
c'est une gestion rigoureuse d'un budget
dont on ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui ne pas
pouvoir étendre le périmètre sans risque
si on veut retrouver de l'indépendance
et de la souveraineté face aux marchés
financiers
il faut qu'on réduise d'un déficit
budgétaire et il faut qu'on évite de
faire exploser la dette
vous voyez ce qui peut se passer dans
d'autres pays on a intérêt d'être
extrêmement vigilant donc c'est
simplement une question de bonne gestion
je vais revenir sur une question qui
concerne directement votre activité de
mise
l'agriculture en question un peu
technique qui s'appelle la
contractualisation depuis la loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture de votre
prédécesseur
les producteurs et les industriels qui
leur achètent leurs produits le lait
doivent passer un contrat vous savez que
les producteurs laitiers notamment
gélade est un producteur laitier du
maine et loire sous les yeux qui
rappelle que dans la filière laitière 53
% de la marge est faite par les
industriels et 30% par la grande
distribution ce qui explique la détresse
du monde agricole aujourd'hui et il
ajoute un propos de ces fameux contrats
pourquoi un contrat de cinq ans en prie
vous savez qu'il n'y a pas de prix
plancher dans ses contrats qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez répondre à cet agriculteur
dans une lettre qui vous étaient
adressées d'abord vous savez oui je sais
et je vais avoir un rapport qui va être
donnée et délivrez-nous 13 juillet c'est
à dire vendredi que j'ai demandée pour
faire le point sur cette
contractualisation laitière
il faut que vous sachiez qu'il ya des
contrats qui sont différents selon les
industriels aujourd'hui et qu'il était
nécessaire pour le ministre de
l'agriculture de faire le point quels
sont les objectifs à partir de là que je
vais chercher à poursuivre il y en a
deux majeurs le premier set permettent
aux agriculteurs producteurs laitiers de
pouvoir s'organiser
c'est la question des groupements qui
peuvent négocier avec les
transformateurs ce qui donne plus de
bois aux producteurs par rapport aux
transformateurs et la deuxième question
qui était dans le paquet les d'ailleurs
européen que j'avais moi même négocié à
l'époque c'est de tenir compte de la
question des prix il ya dans certains
contrats aujourd'hui aucun prix fixé
c'est négocier mensuellement
l'objectif que je vais
c'est de mettre en oeuvre c'est d'avoir
une négociation qui pourrait prendre en
compte une durée de prix plus longue et
dans le paquet européen le fameux paquet
les qu'avec adopté on avait une durée de
six mois et six mois d'accord donc vous
pouvez pour être clair vous pourriez
garantir aux producteurs laitiers pour
qui c'est une question vraiment crucial
que dans quelques mois ils auraient ils
passeraient des contrats avec par
exemple lactalis pour pas le nommer qui
prévoirait qui faisons la réalisation
que je veux un prix pour six mois
cessna négociations que je vais à quelle
échéance dès cet été avec le 13 juillet
je reçois le rapport qui va faire le
point sur l'ensemble des contrats et je
vous le dis en a qui sont différents les
uns des autres donc des clauses de prix
par exemple qu'on était prévu par
certains transformateurs et pas par
d'autres
donc je vais faire le point je rendrai
public ce rapport pour que ça soit
transparent et à partir de là
j'engagerai négociations avant de
revenir avec question purement politique
vous envisagez toujours d'étendre la
politique de contractualisation à la
filière viande alors au vu de ce que je
vais avoir à mettre en oeuvre au niveau
de la contractualisation laitière j'ai
engagé quelques discussions prise de
contact avec un certain nombre de
filières pour savoir si ça les
intéressait dans quelle mesure 16
intéressés est ce que j'ai dit l'arrêt
ce que je viens de l'annoncer aux fins
de dire quelle est ma logique ça
intéresse donc au niveau des
interprofessions en particulier bovines
ça peut intéresser
donc je vais faire le point sur le lait
je vais essayer et d'engager là
négociation sur les bases que j'évoquais
et après il est possible qu'on d'étendre
cette contractualisation avec un
objectif simple c'est de permettre aux
producteurs d'être organisés d'avoir des
filières organisées de ne pas remettre
en cause l'équilibré économique des
transformateurs mais de faire en sorte
que les producteurs soient aussi un peu
entendu travailleurs vous nouvelles
règles du jeu
vous avez été pendant des années le
directeur de cabinet de françois
hollande premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste avant d'être 11 ans 11 ans
vous avez été vous avez occupé ce rôle
quand le parti socialiste temps lionel
jospin était premier ministre une
question à vous avez encore plus de
pouvoirs à quoi sert un parti de gauche
quand quand
quand il à l'exécutif quand il a le
parlement quand il a les plus grandes
villes il s'est enfin on va vers un
parti qui semblait peuvent peu vers une
politique de parti croupion
voilà alors vous répondre ayant vécu les
deux périodes celle d'un parti dans la
majorité avec un premier ministre et
celle d'à parti dans l'opposition
un parti de la majorité d'abord il a des
échéances électorales majeures à
préparer il y en aura dès 2014 donc le
parti socialiste n'est pas sans travail
il ya là l'occasion de justifier
l'existence d'un grand parti comme le
nôtre deuxième point un grand parti tant
la majorité est imparti nécessaire pour
le débat démocratique
il ne peut pas y avoir uniquement un
débat démocratique entre gouvernements
qui s'adresse aux français et un
gouvernement qui s'adresserait
uniquement à l'opposition il doit y
avoir un parti majoritaire qui assume un
rôle démocratique dans le débat qui fixe
une identité politique c'est ce que j'ai
dit aujourd'hui qui donne une lecture
politique de la politique qui est
conduite et qu'il assume comme une
identité politique dans le débat
démocratique donc c'est tout
ce parti le parti mais bien sûr une
autre averse sera toujours alors
toujours des débats y en aura des débats
vous nous dites ça aujourd'hui il ya
trois jours vous souhaitiez quasiment
une motion unique au congrès de toi
aussi aux socialistes
je vous souhaitez mais tout en disant ça
vous souhaitez une motion rim et g10
large rassemblement réunis au congrès de
tout bien sûr que je ne sois un large
rassemblement parce que je pense que il
ya besoin devant des français de se
rassembler aujourd'hui personne ne
comprendrait qu'on s'engage après une
victoire comme celle que nous venons de
vivre dans les difficultés qui sont
d'une autre dans un débat général on
referait et congrès qu on a connu ça a
beaucoup de sel pour les journalistes
qui font les commentaires mais je crois
que devant les français c'est pas ça
qu'ils attendent premier point deuxième
point
quelle identité politique c'est ça que
j'ai voulu dire c'est ça qui est
important c'est pas simplement le
rassemblement pour le rassemblement
c'est nécessaire mais c'est pas
suffisant il faut qu'ils aient mis
politique vous avez conquis le veut le
pouvoir sans ligne politique sans
identité psg aussi ses défauts
expliquent les douloureux à redéfinir
une digue jazz il ya un débat au parti
socialiste il y aura des débats
on sait très bien que le parti
socialiste connais cette diversité
aujourd'hui cette victoire nécessite
qu'on tire les leçons de cette victoire
sur quoi s'est appuyé françois hollande
a ni pourquoi il a rencontré cinq points
clés rapidement ployé rapidement cinq
points clés il ya la question européenne
majeure on est un parti européen alors
on doit assumer ses engagements
on va être un parti décentralisateur y
aura une grande loi de décentralisation
je pense que l'identité des socialistes
aujourd'hui c'est de le revendiquer
demain dire qu'elle est on est un parti
avec françois hollande qui a défini
l'idée du pacte productif c'est à dire
le fait qu'on passe d'une économie
financière à l'économie d'investissement
et de production
c'est nouveau et je le lis cette
question de la production à la question
d'écologie ya une transition écologique
a assuré et puis on a un parti sur la
jeunesse l'éducation qui est un enjeu
essentiel
on a défini il ya la république c'est à
dire le fait que moi j'ai constaté après
la victoire de françois hollande
l'idée qu'il y avait à l'apaisement et
que les gens étaient très satisfaits du
fait qu'on est plus là pour stigmatiser
les diviser on va rebaptiser le parti
socialiste alors ça va être le parti
hollandiste non je pense que je tire des
conclusions politiques de ce qui s'est
passé dans la tribune que vous publiez
dans le monde cet après midi vous rendez
un hommage appuyé à martine aubry vous
vous souhaiter qu elle rempile à la tête
du parti socialiste
moi ce que j'ai voulu dire cet après
midi c'est que 1 fallait assumer ses
responsabilités devant les français on
ne peut pas diviser pour se diviser ou
pour le plaisir d'avoir des débats entre
nous pour des postures interne
2 j'ai dit qu'il fallait définir une
identité politique elle est liée à la
victoire de françois hollande ça me
paraît quand même l'essentiel et
troisième point sur le reste la
discussion est ouverte
alors je répète je reprends ma question
parce que je crois que j'ai pas eu de
moi je n'ai pas dresse que vous savez
c'est le seul nom qui apparaît dans
votre tribu et avec les autres est-ce
que vous soumettre les cas marine que
marquise sûr que martin heures
aubry rempile à la tête du parti
socialiste aux primaires je les dis je
n'étais pas forcément favorable aux
primaires au départ et je trouve ça a
été une réussite donc je vais pas non
plus faire comme si j'avais pas à saluer
ce qui s'était passé
on le sait tout ça est un grand moment
démocratique à partir de là moi la
question que je pose sur la table ce que
j'évoque c'est ce que je vous ai dit
pour ce qui est de savoir si martine
aubry doit ou pas reste et c'est à elle
de le dire c'était un coup politique de
m de nommer benoît hamon au gouvernement
alors c'est des bonnes des âmes
charitables au parti socialiste dès
qu'il est le secrétaire d'état aux
tickets resto c'était un coup de maître
de le nommer à ce poste là pour étouffer
la gauche du parti pour museler la
gauche du parti à l'assemblée d'abord il
ya deux choses c'est pas le ticket resto
c'est l'économie sociale et solidaire
j'ai encore vu des coopératives et des
coopérateurs au niveau agricole et des
mutualistes je vous le dis quand même
c'est une économie qui compte
deuxièmement sur tout ce qui va être la
politique de l'emploi
il ya un enjeu majeur dans cette
économie donc le rôle de benoît hamon
que je vais voir et on va discuter de
tout ça et pas simplement sur les
tickets restaurant il est bien au delà
sur comment on utilise cette économie
sociale et solidaire pour développer
l'emploi parce que c'est quand même le
sujet majeur c'est le deuxième point ce
gouvernement a rassemblé tous ceux qui
pendant la campagne de françois hollande
se sont engagés dans cette campagne et
ont soutenu françois donc vous risquez
pas de laisser le monopole de la
contestation à la gauche de la gauche
est à la rue il ya toujours un risque
quand on est aux responsabilités
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être le plus
clair et le plus net possible à la fois
sur les objectifs et les enjeux sur les
perspectives qu'on donne et sur une
identité politique que représente si on
commence à vouloir jouer tous les
tableaux à sont là c'est vrai qu'on
mènera un espace à ceux qui peuvent
contester je comprends c'est pas facile
mais on l'a dit et on doit l'assumer
mais en même temps on doit se projeter
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce congrès et
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce qui a été
engagé par le gouvernement de jean marc
ayrault
je prends la conférence sociale
nouveauté quand même démocratie sociale
pour la première fois c'était à saluer
et moi je le salue vous comprendriez
qu'une partie du groupe socialiste
s'abstiennent sur la ratification du
paquet européen qui viendra quand quand
si ça vient à l'assemblée mais quand ça
viendra devant le parlement
moi je pense qu'il ya un engagement
européen je les dis et qui a eu un choix
fait par françois hollande qui a été
concrétisé
il avait dit il ne peut pas y avoir des
traités d'austérité sans croissance et
sans engagement sur la croissance et
l'investissement
vous l'avez vu toute la première les
premières semaines ce débat a été porté
il ya eu un changement de ton à
l'échelle de l'europe
on a assommé qui a eu lieu qui a tiré
des conclusions
je pense que ces conclusions sont très
importantes et un changement dit à
l'échelle de danger social is love
l'entente devront comprendre c'est
conforme à ce qui a été l'engagement de
france roland on est dans une position
où la france et le président de la
république ont modifié et changer la
ligne qui était celle précédemment posé
sur la table au niveau européen c'est ça
qui compte et c'est ça l'enjeu majeur
vous avez parlé de la conférence sociale
il y a un thème qui s'imposent
aujourd'hui qui s'est imposé d'ailleurs
le chef de l'état on en parlait il en
parlait moins durant la campagne
présidentielle c'est l'accord
productivité des entreprises alléger le
coût du travail en a pas franchement
parler pendant sa campagne reconnaissait
le et donc le chantier éviter pacte
productif a été pas l'un pour les trois
grands thèmes qui avait été déposée par
françois hollande à lorient au mois de
mai la main 2000 pour alléger le coût du
travail qui donc est un problème c'est
reconnu vous ne voulez pas de la tva il
vous reste la csg la question de des
cotisations qui est posée c'est à dire
ce qu'on appelle les cotisations
sociales et l'assiette de ces
cotisations
c'est une question qui est posée c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui ça pèse sur le coût
du travail et il ya des pistes sur
lequel on a des réflexions à avoir c'est
ce qu'a proposé été question pendant la
campagne de la csg qui a une base plus
large la valeur ajoutée dans les
entreprises peu différent et puis aussi
peut-être ça avait été évoqué les
questions de taxe sur le carbone
amériques
françois hollande va nous parler le 14
juillet c'est une tradition républicaine
c'est un usage rassure un appel
ces décisions et prier quasi je crois
que ma part oui oui mais va le faire sur
une plateaux télé je crois oui
absolument
qu'est ce qu'il doit dire quelle mais
l'esprit vers alger doit dire au
président de la république ce qui ne
doit dira ce qu'il en est de vous dire
c'est bien vous êtes un poids je connais
bien oui les messages doit-il passer aux
français la longue séquence où il a été
tenu à l'écart de la scène nationale
puisqu'il était pris par les rendez vous
européens
je sais aussi les rendez vous européens
et internationaux qui concernait les
français la question de l'europe par
définition est très importante
hélas il n'en compte 14 juillet il ya
une déclaration de politique générale il
ya un cadre a été fixé il ya une grande
conférence soit démocratie sociale qui a
été engagé il a fait un très beau
discours d'ailleurs au conseil
économique et social et environnemental
donc je pense qu'il a de quoi sur ces
grands sujets là à s'adresser aux
français voilà on est jeune on aurait
pas de conseils
on attendra le 14 juillet tous ensemble
mais revenir vite plus beaucoup
attendent merci samir perrine tarneaud
de public sénat arrive donc juste après
cette enquête
suivez sur vous paul séguin grainier
grainier tanguera nuit longtemps
stéphane le foll a officié dans l'ombre
de françois hollande élu député européen
en 2004 et les restes et son directeur
de cabinet en parallèle impossible de
mettre fin à ce duo qui se connaît
depuis longtemps très longtemps
stéphane a travaillé avec françois
pendant 17 ans 17 ans donc c'est pas
rien dur inflexible stéphane le foll se
traîne longtemps la réputation de
porte-flingue un apparatchik dit on
toujours au service de françois hollande
la fidélité c'est notre point commun
déjà à la base tout comme faouzi
lamdaoui stéphane le foll a vécu la
traversée du désert de françois hollande
et dès 2008 c'est lui le pilier de ces
irréductibles qui croient en un possible
aujourd'hui le voilà récompensé nommé à
la tête du ministère de l'agriculture
dont il est spécialiste et même dans
l'opposition on reconnaît sa compétence
dans le casting gouvernemental
on peut avoir des doutes sur les
positionnements des uns et des autres
pensent qu'ils concernent où il est
vraiment une place sur lesquels il a
une autorité qui et qui est reconnue et
qui s'appuie vraiment sûr du travail au
cours de ces dernières années
et pourtant le poste a failli lui passer
sous le nez françois hollande refusant
de mieux traiter ses proches que les
autres place aux autres tendances du ps
mais aussi aux alliés d'europe écologie
les verts des alliés qui pourrait poser
de problème pour le nouveau ministre de
l'agriculture
le véritable enjeu finalement il est
assez simple c'est de savoir s'il va
être capable de résister à la pression
d'une partie de ses amis et il faut
faire en sorte également de ne pas être
dans une logique comment dirais-je
environnementalistes qui considérait que
l'idéal pour la nature c'est qu'elle ne
soit pas cultiver bref lance un grognard
de françois hollande trouve aujourd'hui
la lumière et les problèmes qui vont
avec
il n'y avait rien à craindre oui
finalement 1 mais monsieur béchu votre
adversaire de l'ump vous trouve toutes
les qualités
on avait dit à la commission agricole du
parlement raïs et vos voyages comme un
vers bruxelles et strasbourg ont forgé
manifestement une amitié politique au
delà des divergences idéologiques
bonsoir perrine tarneaud on va revenir
un petit peu sur votre parcours sur
votre réputation de porte-flingue de
françois hollande qui date vous longues
années de compagnonnage avec lui au sein
du parti socialiste est vrai que vous
avez longtemps été ce grand type dans
l'ombre de françois hollande qui avait
un peu au parti socialiste le rôle du
coeur alors que le premier secrétaire
lui cultiver un peu plus ses rondeurs
moi j'aime était un tueur cu
par contre une détermination sans faille
à soutenir françois hollande à le faire
dans l'esprit qui était sien
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait aussi à
composer
je crois que le parti socialiste ça lui
a été reproché d hautmont du congrès de
reims cette espèce de synthèse d'
équilibre qu'il trouvait toujours et
donc moi j'ai participé à tout ça dont
je n'étais pas plus dans une démarche de
deux tueurs comme ça a été dit souvent
qu'il a exécutée non non non j'ai eu dix
buts et personnel c'est que tout le
monde se retrouvait à haslach capacité
de pouvoir briguer les postes que chacun
pouvait peut être pas pour vous déplaire
cette image
non mais j'ai été à côté de françois
hollande serait élu
une formule qui avait été assez chouette
qui était moins moins violente que celle
que vous utilisez c'était stéphane le
foll est aussi caricom françois hollande
est rond à l'époque c'était il ya quatre
cinq ans ça correspond quant à moi j'ai
un caractère franc et anti mal c'est sûr
j'ai eu deux jeux légué une fidélité à
françois hollande
et puis j'ai une sincérité je suis parti
en étant élu à 23 ans d'un petit village
de 256 habitants donc j'ai une carrière
qui est un peu différent d'après du
sport est proche et pas fait ce qu'on
peut faire d'autre et que je respecte
mais j'ai donc cette caractéristique la
voilà vous avez eu une vie avant d'être
un homme politique et pourtant vous
traînez aussi une réputation
d'apparatchiks oui ben j'ai fait 11 ans
directeur de cabinet par définition ça
laisse quelques traces et on peut
imaginer que on peut penser que je n'ai
rien fait d'autre bon j'ai fait d'autres
choses mais j'ai été là oui longtemps et
donc ça laisse des traces là mais je
crois que j'ai su et je sais à la fois
assumer les responsabilités qui ont été
les miennes et en même temps garder bien
d'autres qualités ou celle que vous non
j'espère que je vais sourire j'ai lu
cette définition de votre relation de
françois hollande lui-même
je suis petit il est grand il est très
dur et moi je suis plutôt souple mais
les durs d'apparence sont sensibles et
les souples inflexible est ce que c'est
un bon portrait c'est moi qui ai dit ça
fasse vendre soit toujours là paru comme
quelqu'un qui était tout à fait
sympathique avenant et c'est vrai si on
met la détermination totale la preuve
la preuve et ceux qui ont cru donc une
apparence qui trompe
oui il se conclut justement que c'est l
apparence qui comptait se sont donnés
les doigts pour certains bref je peux
pas revenir sur toute cette histoire
mais en même temps oui ben grand
monsieur pourquoi et en même temps
sensible sensibles comme tout le monde
d'ailleurs je ne crois je dis tu voulais
pas revenir sur toute cette histoire de
la campagne des critiques à l'encontre
de françois hollande avec tellement
critique si vous voulez que j'en ai
sélectionne les oublier
c'est à dire c'est françois hollande qui
lui sauve aux gg pas de mémoire ouais
voilà c'est pas pas mal mais il a dit
aussi vis-à-vis de ses amis exactement
oui de ses amis ses véritables d'amis
les îles et dans des choix il les fait
par rapport à des enjeux et des
stratégies politiques
ça veut dire quand on est au pouvoir
pour atteindre ses objectifs finalement
on n'a plus d'amis
j'ai senti que ça n'a pas empêché de
garder de l'amitié puis quelqu'un de son
entourage dit aujourd'hui de françois
hollande que il a toutes les qualités de
françois mitterrand sauf la fidélité à
ses amis moi je crois pas c'est plus
compliqué puis vous savez quand on est à
la tête et qu'on arrive comme ça j'ai vu
tout je suis bien placé pour vous dire
que c'est jamais facile et donc je moi
je suis pas là pour faire des procès et
surtout on suffisamment d'années avec
françois hollande pour savoir aussi que
il a comme d'autres beaucoup de
sensibilité malgré le fait qu'il soit
déterminé c'est quelqu'un de très
sensible dont je ne vous crois pas du
tout à ce ce qui vient d'être dit je
pense que il garde et c'est sa force
aussi une profonde humanité
on a dans cette émission un partenariat
avec orange et leur application tv
tchèque alors il ya des questions qui
nous arrive des internautes
aujourd'hui ça marche une question
notamment de caroline vous n'avez pas
peur que françois hollande s'enferment
dans la solitude du pouvoir
c'est toujours une vraie question à ce
que le pouvoir isole et comment on sort
de l'isolément du pouvoir oui je crois
je crois parce qu'il a besoin lui
d'aller au contact des gens c'est
quelqu'un qui aime bien aller à la
recherche et aux contacts donc voilà je
trouve qu'ils se protègent contre ces
risques
quand il faudrait je pense qu'il va
organiser des déplacements on y va sur
une présence je pense que bon voilà
c'est lui qui va choisir
je pense que c'est vrai et dans le temps
particulier vous faire très attention ça
des parlementaires socialistes s'insurge
aujourd'hui contre le choix de jean
pierre jouyet pour diriger la caisse des
dépôts va pas me lefrançois exactement
très proche de françois hollande mais il
est aussi un ministre d'ouverture de
nicolas sarkozy est ce qu'on devrait
à ce titre lui barrer la route moi je ne
crois pas il est aujourd'hui à la tête
de l'as de l'agent de la compo des
marchés financiers dont un enregistré sa
main telle autorité voilà en train de
chercher j'avais perdu autorité des
marchés financiers aemf et il exerçait
totori cette autorité ou se dirige cette
cette autorité avec les compétences
qu'on lui connaît il a pris des
positions d'ailleurs sur la question
financière sur la crise financière qui
n'était pas celle qu'on a pu entendre de
la part d'autres c'est cela qui lui est
reprochée par les socialistes a été ré
nice des affaires européennes qui
restait un an
oui au moment où le bouclier et je pense
que sur la caisse des dépôts ce qui les
dérange de leurs terres socialistes
d'avoir été ministre dans un
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy au
moment le bouclier fiscal a été créé au
moment où il y avait un ministère de
l'identité nationale est ce que vous
faisiez vous choque qu'ils puissent y
être je je connais bien enfin je connais
un peu jean pierre jouyet
j'ai côtoyé au parlement européen à
cette époque là je sais ce qui me disait
sur un certain nombre de sujets que vous
évoquez est d'ailleurs il l'a quittée
très vite ce gouvernement il a été nommé
où là il est resté le temps de la
présidence française européenne vous en
souvenez voilà ce qu'il a fait et je
crois pas que dans ses prises de
positions quelquefois quelques à
quelques occasions que ce soit y ait eu
un dérapage ou une prise de position qui
ne soit pas conforme aux valeurs que
nous défendons et la caisse des dépôts
avec l'enjeu qui a derrière de la banque
publique d'investissement est un enjeu
où il faut quelqu'un qui puisse avoir
les compétences pour guider et dirigé
cette visite aux députés et sénateurs
socialistes et que vous dites il faut
savoir comprendre et pardonner
il faut savoir comprendre et pardonner
comprendre et pardonner par ancienneté
dans le gouvernement il faut savoir
comprendre
il ya des sujets majeurs et en
particulier cette caisse des dépôts donc
il faut des gens compétents
je ne crois pas que là dessus on puisse
considérer que jean-pierre juillet n'est
pas les compétences donc il a les
compétences
j'oublie pas d'ailleurs parce que ça
c'est facile mais il a été quoi aussi
jean pierre jouyet avant le directeur
adjoint de cabinet de monsieur de leurs
nationaux mais les deux et deux modèles
oui la justice il a des titres non
pasqua mais non par le cépage porte-voix
de certains élus socialistes mais on
veut savoir si vous travaillez leur
réunion vous avez répondu comprendre et
pardonner
toujours via orange est une question qui
nous arrive de serge papin qui dirige
système u serge papin qui vous demande
vous avez évoqué le souhait de nouveau
modèle productif pour l'agriculture
quelle serait alors la place de la
grande distribution dans leur
élaboration
aucune place à la grande discussion n'a
rien à voir avec les techniques et des
modèles de production agricole il s'agit
d'agronomie
il s'agit de t'écoute de production ne
vois pas quel est le rapport
la grande distribution distribue des
produits finis transformer très bien là
il s'agit de se poser des questions pour
savoir comment ont réussi à assurer une
transition vers la durabilité pour
l'ensemble de l'agriculture s'agit pas
uniquement de dire et fixer les
objectifs en terme de surface par
exemple sur l'agriculture bio qu'il
faudra développer
il s'agit aussi de se poser la question
de la transition globale de
l'agriculture moins de pesticides moins
d'herbicides moelleux consommation
énergétique moins d'engrais minéraux
c'est ça l'enjeu et il ya des modèles
aujourd'hui il ya des techniques qu'il
faut développer et c'est ça mais ce ne
veut ni en tout la logique environnants
environnementalistes pardon va dominer
c'est pas logique environnementalistes
c'est une logique qui consiste à dire
que sur les pesticides comme les
herbicides la chimie on peut faire aussi
bien avec beaucoup moins et ça serait
complètement ridicule de se priver de
cet enjeu la deuxième en moins vous
consommez de consommations
intermédiaires moi vous avez de risque
de polluer et plus vous êtes capable de
dégager je lui rajoute pour les
agriculteurs de la marge brute à l'état
donc à la fois un intérêt écologique
environnemental et économique c'est
l'enjeu du débat que je vais ouvrir sur
ces questions donc raccourcir les
circuits économiques
non là je répété je vois là vous me
parlez de modèles de production
c'est-à-dire les techniques culturales
oui comment on produit vous êtes dans un
jardin
quand vous faites des jardins vous
bêcher booth solaire vous récoltez après
en distribuer on transporte et bien pour
bêcher on peut se passer du bêchage par
exemple pouvait mettre de la moutarde
vous alléger votre terrain coupez votre
portable vous pouvez fixer de la zone
est derrière vous pouvez sommet c'est un
changement de techniques culturales
c'est la réponse à monsieur pape est en
tous les cas je me laisse à la
redistribution pensez bien
je me souviens de la polémique après les
attentats terroristes à toulouse à la
fin du quinquennat et notamment de la
volonté du parti socialiste de créer une
mission d'information parlementaire pour
comprendre un peu les zones d'ombré dans
cette affaire là et pourquoi aujourd'hui
vous condamner la publication des
enregistrements audio du terroriste avec
son agent traitant alors que justement
elles font apparaître ils font
apparaître ses enregistrements les
fameuses zones d'ombré que vous souvent
le problème qui a aujourd'hui c'est que
les victimes parce qu'il faut y penser
loughner découvert ces enregistrements
comme tout le monde à la télévision
elles sont les premières concernées on
ne peut pas faire ça comme ça sans avoir
une discussion sur les enjeux sur le
rôle et sans et les prévenir ou discuter
avec elles c'est ça qui me choque parce
qu'au bout du compte il ya besoin de là
dessus d'y voir clair il ya un jugement
il ya une enquête qui doit être fait
mais vis-à-vis des victimes et ça je les
dis je le répète j'ai trouvé que c'était
une manière qui consistait à dire j'ai
informé tout le monde je me préoccupe
pas des victimes c'est quand même alors
qu'ils ont subies juste toujours que
j'ai dit une mise en garde de ces ça
c'est à dire pas de sanction quoi c'est
juste un petit avertissement ça vous
paraît suffisant mais moi je veux pas
parler à leur avis et ça je vous dis ce
que je pense je pense que c'était pas
bien de faire ce qui a été fait et de
d'annoncer ça comme ça delaunay au grand
public sans avoir dix prévenus discuter
avec les victimes
très bien merci à vous merci perrine
c'est le dernier preuves par 3 de la
saison en bosnie du temps alors dès que
j'ai dans de vacances vous reviendrai
plus tard on a un très bon été et a très
vite
un homme qui appartient
je ne sais à quelle trop pays qu'elle
quel continent et qui acceptent de
donner sa vie pour un pays dont il n'est
pas pour moi c'est le conte français par
le sang versé
ou comment une loi fini par permettre
aux légionnaires blessés au combat
d'acquérir la nationalité française
on a servi à un pays avec des armes et
en blessèrent pour moi sacré elle y est
je sais pas ça ça m'a dit que maintenant
c'est moi je vais finir ma vie français
par le sang versé
samedi à 22 heures sur public sénat d'où
le matin à 8h15 guillaume durand et
gilles leclair reçoivent une
personnalité politique dans en route
vers la présidentielle d'élection
présidentielle de 2012 en tout état de
cause sera extraordinairement difficile
je sais qu'il ya ma candidate c'est un
joli adversaire c'est la droite le grand
courant du centre en france a le droit
de voir d'être présent dans cette
élection il faut faire ce que marine
prennent à 10 en partenariat avec radio
classique
en route vers la présidentielle tous les
matins à 8h 15 en direct sur public
sénat
chaque année 70 mille personnes sont
hospitalisées sans leur consentement
alors que la loi qui encadre ces
hospitalisations vient d'être réformé la
réalisatrice lorène debaisieux a enquêté
sur le monde de la psychiatrie
j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui
me semble encore très tabou
je pense que la folie fait peur encore
aujourd'hui et que j'avais envie de
parler des fractures de la société s'en
fait partie et je pense que c'est une
manière de décrire la société que de
raconter comment la société traite c'est
fou c'est un ange allure dans des
prisons aussi c'est une façon de voir
quel est le niveau d'une société
exactement pas rare de voir comment elle
gère à la marge les personnes ne font
pas dans le circuit de pas la
consommation privée liberté
c'est un enjeu important parce que il ya
à peu près 70 mille personnes qui sont
hospitalisées sous contrainte par an et
que ça correspond à peu près au nombre
de personnes qui sont incarcérés
c'est équivalent donc c'est vrai que
c'est comparable l'enjeu est important
et voilà nous semblait important de
donner la parole aux personnes
concernées parce qu'à ce qui est dur
dans l'histoire mais vous êtes la mère
d'un enfant comme ça qu'on demande à
hospitaliser c'est quoi c'est la
trahison qu'on semble lui faire c'est la
peur de se tromper c'est quoi là j'avais
pas peur de me tromper toute façon je
suis pas tout seul dans le gag c'est une
mère ne veut pas hospitaliser son enfant
de force il n'ya pas l'avis du
psychiatre
donc il ya des médecins qui vous appuyez
ou chivu non qu'ils disent oui mais il
n'ya pas que vous vous vous le demander
mais bon ce qui est c'est vous voyez
votre enfant partir dans une ambulance
en ayant une piqûre calmantes de force
dans la fesse voilà il vous suivez vous
arrivez en pleine nuit dans un hôpital
psychiatrique que ça soit sainte-anne
polizzaro d'autres c'est quand même un
peu style asile du 19e siècle
donc voilà ma fille me disait tu m'as
fait interner chez les fous non je t'ai
fait hospitaliser parce que tu es malade
et tu as besoin
il a reproché
plusieurs fois c'est terrible pour pour
avoir la conscience après récupérer elle
peut elle comprend pas elle veut pas et
puis petit à petit petit à petit il ya
quand même une espèce de compréhension
que ça n'est pas vraiment pour lui faire
du mal et que l y trouve aussi elle a
fait la démarche est elle même parfois
d'y aller seul vous en même temps
aujourd'hui elles et eux et je paie des
nations libres a commencé sa joie zidi
aller oui donc c'est une évolution dans
son entraînement et lorsqu'on est à huy
extrait local admis qu'au fil du temps
que vous l'ayez fait le bon choix que
d'appeler des médecins pour la
contraindre à se faire soigner
oui c'est ça oui en gros c'est ça oui
concrètement comment ça se passe quand
on rentre comme ça hospitalisés
allemande d'un tiers ou d'office dans un
hôpital
on n'est pas libre on est enfermé on est
contraint on est attachée ou enfermée
dans une chambre et quoi on est avant
tout protéger c'est le mot mais concret
viendront la vérité c'est quoi pour
protéger ma vérité les faits mais dans
toute la médecine et à des mesures qui
sont prises quand on reçoit quelqu'un
qui est à moitié dans le coma on va
pouvoir on va prendre toutes les
dispositions pour qu'ils se fassent pas
de mal en tombant
nous nous devons faire en sorte que
puisqu'il n'est pas conscient des
troubles dont il souffre qu' il ne part
qu'ils ne quittent pas l'hôpital
immédiatement qu'il ne ne se fasse pas
du mal qu'il ne fasse pas de mal à
d'autres patients enfin c'est toutes ces
mesures je n'en attends de leur
incarcération mais on est on est calme
dans une logique de privation de
contraintes
on peut on le prenait un traitement à
quelqu'un qu'il refuse on peut le faire
pour tous les usages
il faut que les règles on peut le voir
sous ce regard là mais non mais ce n'est
pas un secret dit que c'est une
protection nécessaire et qui n'est pas
discutable puisque l'arrivée du juge
c'est très très difficile à vivre pour
les psychiatres qui jusqu'à présent
était un peu maîtres chez eux et qui
sont maintenant obligés effectivement de
justifier encore une fois la privation
de liberté nous avons eu de longs débats
à l'assemblée pour savoir si le jul
devait aussi intervenir dans
l'obligation de soins il nous est apparu
nous députés toutes tendances politiques
confondues
l'obligation de soin à domicile et à
l'extérieur extérieur à quelques
nouveautés d'alois aussi indépendamment
obliger les soi mais là il n'ya pas le
regard des juges pour l'instant
indépendamment voilà de la privation de
liberté il nous a semblé que le juge
n'avait pas à intervenir sur
l'obligation de soin ça c'est le rôle du
médecin seul rôle du psychiatre
à côté de ça la notion de privation de
liberté elle est fondamentale qui est ça
ce n'est pas du ressort du médecin c'est
vraiment du ressort du juge de la
liberté à savoir si je suis totalement
patient est en mesure ou pas de sortir
alors ça se passe plus ou moins bien
selon les juges se déplace à l'hôpital
ou pas nous avons aujourd'hui dans les
auditions que nous avons mené le premier
bilan montre qu environ 30% des juges se
déplace dans les hôpitaux et dans ce cas
là ça se passe globalement très bien est
ce qu'ils comprennent bien vous êtes de
leur côté par en face et comment ça se
passe ce qu'ils sont vraiment à ce qu'il
souhaite vendre ses tresses est très
variable à dire que il est tout une
certain nombre de patients qu'ils
comprennent